walk me back to where uh it's 2008 and
you're getting sober yeah at that point
you're how old 21 21 years old and um I
I understand you were a full-on child
star is that fair to say sure okay at
what age did you become famous I guess I
I would say I started working I started
working in New York as a standup
comedian when I was 10 wow and I got my
first job which was a show called The
Amanda Show which was like sketch comedy
for kids Amanda B's like crazy brilliant
oh wow Beyond her years Talent still is
and I was 13 and that moved me out to
California and in that day and age
basically the runway was if you were
remotely funny and you were on one kid
show you were probably going to get a
show with your name in it too yeah and
Keenan and Kell had been off for a
couple years they needed another buddy
comedy and here comes Drake and Josh it
blows my mind that a 10-year-old is
going on stage and to be funny right
what kind of what kind of jokes does a
10-year-old have observational
baby you know what's the deal with the
fruit
rups do you remember any of your actual
jokes when you were 10 no I I remember
making I made fun of my mom I made fun
of kids at school I I did impr I did bad
prob like Billy Madison Impressions and
but I had a tight five and I would go to
these comedy
clubs D that's so great to 10-year-old
is really one minute but it felt like
five minutes probably just the audience
being nice to me and not wanting to cut
my head off Where Were You Who what was
your audience school or like older
people so I found this agent named Sid
gold gold star entertainment the father
of Elon Gold the great comedian and uh I
was reading this newspaper I was 9 years
old and I would just do like kids
theater and whatnot at school school
plays and whatnot but like any kid who
plays Little League Dreams of being in
the major leagues I would like look
around at these kids in my school play
and I'd be like you guys got to get your
[__] game up you really like cuz I
was so I loved it and they just did it
for fun and they were probably much
healthier about it but I wanted to do it
at a high level so I I'm reading this
magazine for actors called backstage
there's this guy Sid gold
I represent performers of all ages and I
said well I
qualify and I go to his office he's like
well I I represent Comedians and if you
can get five minutes together I will put
you up at Caroline's comedy club wow
yeah and that's how it started wow yeah
were you nervous like getting on stage
at that young of an age I think it's
like skateboarding or anything like
where the under like I I I tried skiing
for the first time at 30 and I quickly
was like this is insane like this is so
dangerous this is no way to learn
something and so like anything like that
I I feel like it's better to learn young
because your understanding of risk and
pain is so much lower okay I just like
it was standup I just was like I I yeah
I I certainly was nervous and I would
know if one one performance went better
than the other but I was a little
Fearless I would say yeah that's great
man how often did you PR form your type
five twice a week twice a week for how
long 5 years wow and same material no I
would update a little bit and then
because then I would also cash it out
because I'd go perform on Rosie
O'Donnell or wow was tight five yeah
eventually got to a tight 10 and I I got
to get back to work you know I got to
throw out the old [__] that was 10 and
then you started doing uh Josh and Drake
Drake and Josh at 12 no and not until I
was about 15 I did Amanda Show at 13
right okay and and when are you
performing standup comedy on the Rosie
O'Donnell show this is a great story so
I'm like 10 years old and my mom's like
typical Jewish mother and we just go to
see the Ros oon show but at that time
she would have people from the audience
introduce her so there's this guy
running around in the headset right my
mom being like I'm not standing in
line
yeah she goes come here she's like got a
young comedian here you need him yeah
and he's like well give me a joke I told
him a joke five minutes later we're in
the Green Room of the Rosie o'donell
Show wow and then my mom's like well we
didn't get this far to get this far like
you're going to tell her after you
introduce her that you're a kid comedian
and you want to sing a song and do a bit
with her and I was like yes Mom just
love me and where's Dad
um
and and that's exactly what happened wow
yeah so how was it received on on Rosie
and and how much of a of a bit did you
get to do I did a joke I sang with her
we did like some Broadway show tune
something that was in my key in my
register and uh you know at that time it
was just so I was just always ready to
go like whether it was catch a rising
star or standup New York called and
they've got five minutes tonight if you
want to come in and Sub in so my mom
would be like take a nap cuz you're not
going up till till midnight and they're
going to have to sneak you in through
the back it was like I was always ready
to go at that time it was my thing what
year was that um 90 it was probably like
95 through wow uh two I mean all the way
I moved to LA in 2000 we're um
presumably to do this bit on the Rosie
O'Donald show like there was a rehearsal
no no rehearsal no rehearsal so just on
the Fly and in order to sing a song
you're not doing it AC capella right
like uh he she hadn't her kind of Andy
RoR was this this uh great pianist who
was like a classically trained Broadway
Pian so he could play anything so it was
like if you gave him anything within
like the last 40 Years of the the Rogers
and Hammerstein song book he was ready
to go and and I just remember I remember
I think I remember the intro was like hi
I'm Josh peek and this is a Rosie
odonald Show on today's show uh Mike
Meyers wow Robert Wagner and John sakata
hit it
John very cool oh you'll find it and
there you go and cut
it that's very cool that's fantastic
after you did that was your phone
ringing did you get more gigs from that
or I I didn't but I I would audition at
Nickelodeon Every Day for something like
a commercial or uh two lines on it on
one of their shows they had their
offices I'm sure where you've been a
million times at 1515 Broadway s oh 15 I
was thinking Santa Monica but yeah New
York yeah New York because it was MTV
and TRL shot there and and so I would
just get really close but they they
really never wanted me I would audition
for this show all that which was like
SNL for kids the best show it's my dream
all that was so good I wanted it so bad
and they were like not ready
kid they just didn't want me and but I
find I booked this movie with Chevy
Chase and Chris Elliott and Iggy Pop and
cam GRE and it was a Nickelodeon movie
called snow day and I'm on set and the
president of Nickelodeon's hanging out
and my mom being who she is was like
tell them you want to be on all that
tell them you love this [__] give him a
joke and I did and nine months later he
called and said I'm moving you and your
mom to California you're on The Amanda
Show congratulations W so sick that
changed you're like The Amanda Show
[__] man I wanted to be on all that
I really did I really did not until I
got there and I was like yo cuz at 13
amongst my friends I was certainly like
maybe the most talented kid and then you
go into like a ring with Amanda bnch and
you're like I I have nothing on you like
you're so much further ahead of me um
now when you were going to 1515 Broadway
like just on a regular basis just
showing up and just trying to
whose motivation was it was it like you
telling your mom mom I want to go and
and and just show up at the building or
was your mom saying Josh we're going to
go show up at the building
both in hindsight both but you know I
loved it and I was was I I I was pretty
good and so it was your mom it was
myom do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and sto's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude